the grind sucks sometimes you probably
never work a day in your life because
there's a lot of stuff that sucks it's
like I don't [ __ ] like doing billing
like that's terrible like that's not fun
talking to 20 different people every
single day since May 1st about whether
they want to sign up for something is
not fun but it's the thing that I need
to do to fulfill my role right now just
name your sacrifices and usually if you
name those then the actual doing part
gets easy because you're like well what
am I gonna do like for me I get home I'm
like what else am I gonna do but keep
working on this thing anyways lots of
love for everyone I hope everyone's have
an awesome day ah I agree with young
Mosey it just depends on where you're at
in the journey I remember that
particular video I had to confront the
fact that I was like I just don't think
I'm gonna be able to take weekends
anymore I think a lot of times we have
to just sacrifice to small things in
order to get the big things a lot of
people are willing to make that
sacrifice a lot of people believe the
lie that you should enjoy every aspect
of business which is just setting people
up for failure I think if you embrace
the suck if you embrace the sacrifice if
you embrace the things that you're no
longer going to be able to do that you
wish you could do embrace the fact that
you're gonna have to start doing things
that you don't want to do in order to
get where you want to go you have to
believe in that dream enough that you're
willing to do all those things in order
to get there and drag that dream into
the present